how many books have you read and
completely forgotten how many things
have you highlighted and underlined in a
book and just you know never looked at
again do you sometimes feel that it's
completely pointless to start reading
another book because you've never
actually used the one that you just
finished are you semi-anxious when you
are reading because you don't know what
to highlight or on the other end what
not to highlight because all of it just
feels completely pointless and useless
anyways well i find that these issues
come up again and again with reading and
i feel that at the crux of everything it
is an issue with the way that we are
processing our notes and the way that we
are reading in general especially
because i feel a lot of our reading is
done very very passively the thing that
works the most when reading often is
just our eyes and our brains are not
doing a lot of the work especially when
we are done with the book i think this
is a key time where you can make the
most out of everything you've just gone
through whenever we have an instinct
which i think as readers we're very very
familiar with to highlight or save
something all we do is just bold it or
underline it or highlight it somewhere
and let it be when in its essence
anything that provokes us to want to
save it is an opportunity for us to do a
thought exercise an opportunity for us
to have a discussion an opportunity for
us to create something think about
something change have a new learning
point and all we're doing with this is
completely letting it go so to combat
this issue i have a personal formula
that i use every single time that i read
a book and especially when i am done
reading this book and i wanted to share
it with you today and of all the crazy
over-the-top note-taking things that i
do this is one that i would genuinely
recommend to everyone who ever reads a
book it's not that complicated and i
have a free notion template if you just
want to download it somewhere but in
this video i'm going to go through
exactly how i use it why it is so useful
and why i feel it helps me so much with
retaining and learning more from the
books that i read all the time so let's
get started the first part of the
formula is the impressions bit and this
is something that is more of a stream of
consciousness it tends to be sentences
that i write here and there as i'm
reading a book based on the things that
i find interesting or the impressions
that i have from the book so this might
be things like oh i find this book to be
a bit condescending or i find this book
to be very very engaging i find it to be
life-changing i find the language to be
very entertaining or these are parts of
my life that i thought this book would
be the most useful at this would be
recommendations for the type of people
to read this book so this is just like a
general vague impression you can think
of it as kind of a summary in the
newspaper or a recommendation or a
restaurant review so this is the kind of
tone that i will put in this part of the
reflection and i will fill it in as i am
reading the book it will usually be
three to five sentences in general but
it's enough for me to look at every time
that i go back to my book reviews and go
aha yeah i remember what i felt like
when i was reading the book because very
often i forget this impression that i
have now the second part is the key part
of the note-taking process and this is
the actionable takeaways in the past
when i used to read books all i used to
do is keep notes from the books which
would be just highlights or comments on
the things that i was highlighting but i
made this sort of mindset shift when i
thought i'm not finding books useful i'm
not seeing that they are changing my
life and i think the reason for that is
that i'm not applying anything or
looking at things in a book in a way
that i can apply them to my personal
life so at this stage what i decided was
that every single time that i found
something interesting in a book or
highlightable in a book i would take a
second either while i am reading or if
i'm in the flow or in the zone after i'm
done with the book and think about how
this can be applied to a change for my
life so i have to think of actively how
can i apply this to me so for example if
i was reading a book about creativity
and the author was talking about this
famous writer who every night before he
went to bed dreamed of something to look
forward to the next day and this really
impacted the way that he works i won't
just underline this i will actively turn
this into a sentence that is applicable
to me so i will say go to sleep every
day with something you're looking
forward to the next morning because this
will make you more happy to wake up and
eventually your day will be filled of
things that you are looking forward to
doing so even by just changing the words
in this highlight i am converting it
into something i can personally use
rather than just a story about someone
else's life and i will go very overboard
with this in this actionable takeaways
bit i will convert everything that i
find interesting in a book into
something that i can apply to my own
life or to other people's lives
otherwise it will not go in this section
so every single note i'm underlining i'm
converting it in my mind into this thing
and also another thing that i like to do
is i keep this only to 10 quotes which
can be extremely difficult for long and
interesting books and the reason for
this is to me
i can underline and highlight hundreds
and hundreds of pieces of information
from a book but it's unlikely therefore
that i will use these so i will keep it
only to my top ten i can highlight other
things and i will put this in an archive
in my book notes so in the bottom will
be all the things that i found
interesting but i will only keep 10
things in this bit of actionable
takeaways and that means that sometimes
i will remove things from it to add
something else but in the end of the day
when i look at my book notes i only want
10 very important ones for each book
that can actually change my life and in
this way i'm approaching the book in a
very active way of thinking rather than
just passively reading the book i'm
thinking okay how can this be applied to
me i use this for fiction too even when
i see characters say things that are
interesting do things that are
interesting when they have a new bit of
insight or when i get to understand the
way that their brains work i start to
think oh can this be applicable to me
and i will still turn this into an
actionable takeaway part number three is
quite straightforward and this is my
favorite quotes from the book and these
are things that can be mentioned and
converted in the actual takeaways to
something else but there are phrases and
words that author has put together so
beautifully that i just want to preserve
them the way they are because either i
might use them in presentations videos
pieces of writing or creation that i
make in the future or i just want to see
them because they're so powerful that i
don't want to paraphrase them myself so
this will usually be three to five maybe
ten if it's a very long very amazing
book of literal quotes that i will take
from the book and i want to save the way
that they are and lastly i have a bonus
section and this is for the books that
are really really groundbreaking
sometimes they will have multiple
questions or a formula that i really
really want to preserve the way that it
is i read this book recently that was
talking about letting go of things and
of loss and it had three very important
questions that you can ask yourself
every time that you lose something and i
think there was something along the
lines of um did you know that you were
going to lose this thing at some point
in the near future how much more time
would you want to have had with this
thing and lastly do you feel that you
are worth any less now that you don't
have this so this three-part formula i
thought was really really kind of strong
and groundbreaking for me so i thought i
wanted to preserve this in the way that
it was in the bonus sections so either
it can be something like this or it can
be advice that a character gives another
character that i find is really really
helpful and sometimes these are
scattered throughout the book or there
will be a character arc or a character
growth arc for someone that i will break
down into steps and i will turn this
into a formula that i will add to my
bonus section because it is in way an
actionable takeaway but it has multiple
steps so it's really interesting and
these are small parts that i can just
keep separate and look at them sometimes
so whenever i'm done with a book i now
have this kind of notion page that has
all of this information on the book so
it kind of has my first impressions on
it and who i would recommend it to then
it has the actionable takeaways 10
things or 10 ways that this book can
change my life then it has some favorite
quotes from the book and these used
these are a lot less than i used to take
before i'm very picky with these now
then i would go into the bonus materials
or anything extra in the book that i
felt was a formula or something that i
want to apply to my life a lot and yep
in this way i feel as though my reading
becomes a lot more active than it used
to be in the past it's not just me kind
of rushing through books and not
thinking about them but i'm really
thinking about how can this add
something to my life that i can hold on
for a very long time and i've genuinely
found that it has made reading and
note-taking so much more pleasurable for
me and also so much more beneficial for
me if you're interested in books i
actually share my summaries broken down
in this form in a free newsletter which
will be linked somewhere down below so
as i read books i very often share some
of them here with you all you can also
download this notion page formula for
free in my description if you have any
note-taking tips i am always very very
keen on knowing about them or any books
that you want to recommend otherwise
thank you so much for spending this time
with me i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day find a brilliant book to
read and don't believe everything you
think thanks bye